-It is time for
"Tonight Show" Hashtags.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
Should say happy birthday
to Tariq Trotter, by the way.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Guys, this is a thing where
each week I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week I sent out
the hashtag...
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
And I asked you
to post your funniest,
most brilliant
dream couple names.
-Ooh.
-Remember, like, Bennifer?
-Right. Love it.
-Yeah.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the US.
-Oh.
-Minutes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for playing along.
I appreciate that.
We do it every week.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
celebrity dream couple posts
from you guys.
Here we go. This first one
is from @KennyOffwo83555.
-Oh.
-He says...
[ Laughter ]
That's good.
-It does.
-Their love is gold.
This one is from
@asg-underscore-grant.
-Oh.
-He says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
That's pretty good.
-It's a throuple.
-Yeah.
-It's a throuple, yeah.
-It's a throuple.
This one's from @GeneInKC.
He says...
There you go.
Honk-honk!
-Blow the doors off.
-Give me a little honk-honk.
This one's from @ElectricJen.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Whew!
-Wow!
-This party --
-Somebody bring
a wet dog in here?
-Does this party got taste?
-Yeah. Mmm.
-This one's from @Jenna2NYC.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
This one's from geoffjeff55.
[ Laughter ]
He says -- You guys know him?
He -- He says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Built this city ♪
♪ Built this city ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Horn blares ]
Like the movie.
-Uh...
[ Chuckles ]
This one's from ajax2727.
He says...
-Oh.
[ Applause ]
-Oh, this is a good one here.
This one's from @comedy66747.
They say...
There you go. Those are
"The Tonight Show" Hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.
We'll be right back with Battle
of the Instant Songwriters.